Si vous ressentez une fatigue visuelle,
des maux de tête, des vertiges, un oeil
sec, des picotements et même des fois une
vision trouble, c'est que vous faites
probablement ces 7 erreurs qui détruisent
vos yeux.
Je vais vous les présenter, vous allez
probablement vous reconnaître dans
certaines de ces erreurs, voire peut-être
toutes, mais rassurez-vous, je vais vous
dire comment venir les corriger pour en
finir avec tous ces problèmes.
Le constat de base, c'est qu'on passe
beaucoup trop de temps devant nos écrans.
D'ailleurs, vous, tout de suite, vous
êtes en train de consommer un écran.
On y passe en moyenne 32 heures par
semaine et 4,5 heures par jour.
D'ailleurs dites-moi maintenant dans les
commentaires est-ce que vous passez plus
de temps ou moins de temps par rapport à
cette moyenne hebdomadaire.
Allez-y !
La première erreur qu'on fait tous, on
met une luminosité beaucoup trop forte sur
nos écrans.
Et tout ça bien évidemment par rapport à
l'éclairage ambiant de votre pièce.
Que vous soyez bien évidemment à
l'intérieur,
ou à l'extérieur.
A l'extérieur ça va plutôt bien parce que
si vous êtes en plein soleil et qu'il fait
beau, la luminosité est très forte sur
votre smartphone et là globalement ça va
bien se passer.
Mais le cas le plus problématique c'est
lorsque vous êtes chez vous qu'il y a
moins de lumière et même pire le soir
lorsque vous allez vous coucher.
Typiquement moi le soir je suis sur mon
smartphone, je suis en train de naviguer,
je regarde du contenu, je regarde des
fois des films, des séries, je navigue sur
YouTube, je suis sur les réseaux sociaux
et j'ai souvent avec une luminosité qui
est beaucoup trop forte sur mon
smartphone.
Ça veut dire que par rapport à la lumière
environnante, je reçois trop de lumière
dans les yeux.
Et ça c'est vraiment pas très bon.
Il faut donc venir régler la luminosité
de son écran en fonction de la lumière de
votre pièce.
Vous pouvez le faire vous directement
manuellement en venant modifier la
luminosité mais c'est un peu fastidieux.
Aujourd'hui les constructeurs que ce soit
sur smartphone, que ce soit sur ordinateur
et même sur télé vous proposent de venir
modifier la luminosité de votre appareil
par rapport à la lumière environnante.
Ça vous évite de venir le faire et ça va
vraiment venir soulager vos yeux.
Il y a un autre point qui est super
important ici.
Pensez toujours à avoir une source
lumineuse près de vous lorsque vous êtes
en train de regarder du contenu sur un
écran.
Ça va une fois de plus venir éviter la
fatigue oculaire et vous aurez ainsi du
temps de meilleure qualité lorsque vous
consultez vos contenus.
Également pensez à ne pas mettre la
luminosité au maximum lorsque vous lisez
un article.
Des fois on a l'impression que parce
qu'on va venir mettre la luminosité à
fond, on pourra consulter plus facilement
son contenu, on aura un meilleur accès à
l'information.
La réalité c'est qu'il y aura toujours
plus de lumière blanche que de textes
écrits en noir donc vos yeux vont
recevoir énormément de lumière et c'est
pas du tout une bonne idée pour eux.
Pensez donc à venir cocher la case sur
vos appareils pour régler la luminosité de
façon automatique et en plus de ça, ce
qui est super cool, c'est que ça sera bien
meilleur pour l'autonomie de vos
appareils.
La deuxième erreur qu'on fait tous, on ne
pense souvent pas à venir activer le dark
mode sur nos appareils et ça c'est très
important pour le soir.
Le soir c'est toujours le moment un petit
peu critique.
Il n'y a pas de lumière, peu de lumière
et on reçoit une avalanche de lumière au
travers de nos écrans.
Si vous activez le dark mode, qu'est-ce
qui va venir se passer sur votre
smartphone ou sur votre tablette ou sur
votre ordinateur ?
Une partie de l'écran va devenir noire.
Ça évitera donc de recevoir beaucoup trop
de lumière et ça va donc venir protéger
vos yeux.
Une fois de plus, la plupart des
constructeurs permettent d'avoir un switch
intelligent. Pas tous, mais beaucoup.
C'est notamment le cas sur un iPhone ou
sur un Mac.
Il va venir faire le switch
automatiquement.
Comme ça pas besoin de venir vous en
occuper.
L'autre point qui très est cool ici,
c'est que si vous avez un écran OLED, un
pixel noir est un pixel éteint.
Donc vous allez venir préserver
l'autonomie de vos appareils.
La troisième erreur qu'on fait tous, on
ne se protège pas assez de la lumière
bleue.
Vous comme moi, je ne fais pas assez
attention aux risques liés à la lumière
bleue.
Et pourtant c'est un vrai problème.
La lumière bleue, c'est une lumière qui
est de l'ordre du visible.
Si vous regardez le spectre des lumières
qu'on va pouvoir voir, vous verrez que la
lumière bleue, elle se situe juste en
bas, juste avant les ultraviolets qui sont
des lumières qu'on ne voit pas.
La lumière bleue est donc bien une
lumière qu'on voit, c'est le bleu, et qui
a un côté très néfaste pour la santé.
Elle pose des problèmes par rapport au
sommeil.
Elle va venir ralentir la production de
mélatonine.
La mélatonine, c'est l'hormone du
sommeil.
Ça va donc venir retarder la période
d'endormissement.
Vous aurez aussi probablement des
périodes d'insomnie, de réveil dans la
nuit et un sommeil de mauvaise qualité.
Autre problème ce sont les troubles de la
vision.
À terme, ça peut venir endommager votre
rétine.
Et entre temps, vous aurez tous les
problèmes avec des yeux secs, irrités et
une vision floue. Ce n'est pas terrible.
Sans oublier des troubles psychologiques
auxquels on pense pas nécessairement.
Ça va venir influer sur l'humeur et il y
a également un risque de dépression
derrière.
Donc vous voyez cette petite lumière
bleue, elle est franchement hyper
enquiquinante.
Mais rassurez-vous, il existe des
solutions et ça c'est la bonne nouvelle.
On va commencer par faire une chose c'est
baisser la luminosité de nos écrans comme
ça on recevra une quantité de lumière
bien moindre.
Autre chose à faire qui est super
importante c'est régler votre appareil
pour qu'il passe en affichage nocturne.
Pas forcément la journée quand il fait
très beau, mais plus le soir.
Vous allez dans les paramètres et vous
cochez affichage nocturne.
Tous les fabricants vont vous le
proposer.
Des fois ça donne un côté marronné, ce
n'est pas terrible, mais ça va protéger
vos yeux et c'est le plus important.
Autre élément important et on n'y pense
pas, vous pouvez porter des lunettes qui
vont lutter contre la lumière bleue.
Si vous portez des lunettes, peut-être
avez-vous déjà des verres qui vont être
traités pour lutter contre la lumière
bleue.
Mais si vous ne portez pas de lunettes,
vous pouvez aller acheter des lunettes
qui vont venir filtrer cette fameuse
lumière bleue et qui vont éviter tous ces
troubles.
Ça ne veut pas dire qu'il faut venir
mettre la luminosité à fond, non
absolument pas.
Mais c'est un élément supplémentaire qui
va venir jouer en votre faveur.
Et puis le dernier élément qui est le
plus important, évitez les écrans le soir.
Ça c'est également super important aussi.
La quatrième erreur c'est d'acheter un
écran de mauvaise qualité.
Ça m'est déjà arrivé d'acheter des
appareils qui ne coûtaient pas
nécessairement cher.
Et souvent on a la qualité qui va avec.
Alors il n'y a absolument aucun jugement
là-dessus.
On vit tous avec notre budget et on fait
comme on peut.
Mais dès qu'on en a la possibilité, il
faut vraiment venir choisir des appareils
de meilleure qualité qui vont venir
réellement vous protéger.
Privilégiez des appareils qui vont avoir
quelques certifications.
Déjà une certification pour lutter contre
la lumière bleue.
On retrouve notamment TUV Rheinland qui
est un certificateur important et qui est
omniprésent aujourd'hui sur le marché.
C'est gage de qualité.
Il y a TUV Rheinland mais il y en a
d'autres également.
Mais ça il faut vraiment bien le
regarder.
C'est le premier point.
Prenez un moniteur, un écran, un
smartphone, un ordinateur avec un écran
qui est certifié lutter contre la lumière
bleue.
Mais il y a un deuxième point auquel on
pense pas nécessairement lorsqu'on vient
acheter son écran.
Une fois de plus smartphone, tablette et
compagnie.
Et bien c'est qu'il soit certifié avec un
effet anti flicker...
flicker free.
L'effet flicker, ce sont des saccades que
vous n'allez pas voir à l'oeil nu, mais
qui vont réellement vous impacter sur la
fatigue oculaire.
Si vous prenez un écran LCD par exemple
de mauvaise qualité, vous prenez votre
smartphone et vous allez lancer
l'enregistrement en vidéo sur votre écran.
Et là, vous allez voir qu'il y a des
espèces de bandes noires qui viennent se
balader sur votre écran.
Ça c'est l'effet flicker.
Ce sont des choses qui sont
imperceptibles à l'œil nu.
La lumière bleue, l'effet flicker.
Mais ça a un impact extrêmement
considérable sur votre santé visuelle.
La cinquième erreur qu'on fait tous,
absolument tous, on ne fait pas assez de
pause.
On a tendance à enchaîner, je ne sais pas
vous, mais moi c'est mon cas.
Écran après écran après écran.
Là typiquement je vous parle, il y a une
caméra, mais il y a un écran à côté.
Donc je me vois, j'ai un retour
moniteur...
Je prépare cette vidéo, je suis sur mon
ordinateur, vous voyez, c'est pas terrible
non plus.
Ensuite, je vais consulter les réseaux
sociaux, je vais être sur mon smartphone,
peu importe lequel.
Le soir, je vais regarder un film, une
série sur une tablette.
Je vais répondre à mes e-mails sur mon
ordinateur.
Bref, je suis en permanence sur les
écrans.
La moyenne de 4,5 heures par jour, je
peux vous assurer que je suis largement
au-dessus. Et probablement vous aussi.
Donc ça, c'est pas une bonne idée.
Et quitte à passer du temps sur nos
écrans, il faut vraiment tout de suite
prendre une bonne habitude, celle de
faire des pauses.
Des pauses régulières et on se parle pas
de pauses de 10 secondes, tiens, je
regarde ailleurs et j'y retourne.
Non, des vraies pauses.
Attention, je ne parle pas lorsque vous
faites une pause sur votre PC de prendre
votre smartphone.
J'ai fait une pause du PC, j'ai mon
smartphone.
On se parle bien ici de pause d'écran.
C'est important.
Prenez du temps, levez-vous, allez faire
autre chose.
Il est recommandé pour deux heures
d'écran de faire un minimum dix minutes de
pause.
Ce n'est pas énorme, mais c'est déjà un
bon début.
Moi, ce que je vous recommande de faire,
c'est de faire des mini pomodoros.
Si vous connaissez les pomodoros et si ça
vous parle, si c'est pas le cas, faites
une recherche sur le web.
Vous trouverez plein de sujet là-dessus,
mais c'est une façon de gérer son temps.
Vous pouvez vous dire, par exemple, que
pour 25 minutes de temps d'écran, vous
faites une pause entre 3 et 5 minutes.
Ensuite, vous reprenez votre écran 25
minutes, une pause de 3 à 5 minutes.
Ça vous évitera de venir vous abîmer les
yeux et croyez-moi, ça, c'est extrêmement
important.
Et puis le soir, au lieu des fois de
regarder des films, des séries et de
naviguer des heures sur TikTok, mais où
on se rend compte qu'on a passé autant de
temps à regarder globalement pas
grand-chose,
prenez un bon livre et vos yeux vous
remercieront.
La sixième erreur qu'on fait quasiment
tous également, c'est qu'on est toujours
beaucoup trop près physiquement de son
écran.
Moi j'ai une très mauvaise habitude le
soir, je prends ma tablette, je la pose
sur moi et j'ai mon écran devant moi.
Alors je suis content parce que j'ai
l'impression d'être immergé et de regarder
une série ou un film comme si j'étais
presque au cinéma sur un grand écran, mais
la réalité c'est que je bombarde mes yeux
de lumière, c'est beaucoup trop près, ce
n'est pas du tout une bonne idée.
Je sais pas d'ailleurs, est-ce que vous
faites ça vous aussi ?
Dites-le moi dans les commentaires.
Il est recommandé d'avoir une distance
minimale de 50 à 70 cm avec votre
appareil.
Ça veut dire que lorsque vous consultez
votre smartphone, vous ne le regardez pas
comme ça, c'est beaucoup trop près.
50 à 70 cm, on le recule.
Tout de suite, pensez à reculer.
D'ailleurs, je ne sais pas si vous
regardez sur un smartphone, une tablette,
un ordi, une télé peut-être.
Pensez à venir reculer votre appareil.
Une fois de plus, ce sont vos yeux qui
vous remercieront.
Vous avez compris ici, le but, c'est de
mettre de la distance entre vous et vos
appareils électroniques.
Allez, septième erreur, c'est peut-être
plus pour les dinosaures comme moi.
On a une taille de texte qui n'est pas
forcément adaptée à notre vue sur nos
smartphones.
Notamment sur les smartphones mais pas
uniquement.
Tablette et ordinateur une fois de plus.
Ce n'est pas tout de suite mon cas mais
je sens que ça ne va pas tarder à arriver.
Avec l'âge, bien souvent, on a besoin de
venir
augmenter la taille des caractères pour
mieux les lire et éviter de forcer et de
se fatiguer les yeux.
Et fatalement ça génère de la fatigue
oculaire.
Alors qu'est ce qu'il faut faire ?
Vous allez dans les paramètres de votre
smartphone et vous allez augmenter la
taille de la police d'écriture et vous
verrez si au bout d'un moment c'est plus
confortable pour vous, si vous avez moins
à forcer...
D'autant plus que c'est dommage car quand
on arrive à un certain âge, la vision de
près est beaucoup moins bonne.
On va forcément venir reculer son
smartphone ce qui est une bonne chose
parce qu'on reçoit un peu moins de
lumière en direct.
Mais pour autant, il faut venir compenser
en augmentant aussi la taille de la
police.
Si vous n'êtes pas encore dans cet
âge-là, vous verrez un peu plus tard, ça
vous arrivera très probablement.
Au-delà de ces sept erreurs, je vais vous
donner quelques astuces en plus pour venir
corriger ces problèmes et éviter de venir
vous abîmer les yeux.
Alors je vous le dis, je vous le redis et
j'insiste une fois de plus, c'est super
important.
Portez des lunettes pour faire une
barrière contre les lumières bleues,
surtout le soir mais également la
journée.
Protégez vos yeux, protégez vos yeux,
protégez vos yeux.
Autre élément qui est super important, et
je vous le disais, on ne regarde pas de
contenu dans le noir.
Mettez toujours une lumière à proximité.
Alors, si vous regardez la journée et que
vous avez une baie vitrée dans le dos, ce
n'est pas une bonne idée. Pourquoi ?
Parce que vous allez avoir des reflets,
ce n'est pas bien, on bouge, ce n'est pas
très confortable.
Ça ne va pas venir abîmer vos yeux, mais
ce n'est pas confortable.
De la même manière, si vous regardez un
écran, une tablette et compagnie, évitez
de le faire avec une source lumineuse
derrière.
Vos yeux risquent d'être attirés par la
lumière extérieure.
Ce n'est pas idéal, surtout en plein été.
Au printemps, à l'automne, pourquoi pas.
Ce que je vous recommande réellement,
c'est de mettre une source lumineuse sur
le côté.
soit de trois quarts, soit vraiment à
côté.
Pas avec une lumière qui vient
directement éclairer votre écran, ça peut
être un petit peu pénible, mais surtout
qui apporte une source lumineuse et qui va
être bénéfique pour vos yeux.
Et surtout, je le dis, je le redis, c'est
super important, ne jamais regarder ces
écrans dans le noir absolu.
Jamais dans le noir.
Toujours avec une petite source de
lumière.
Alors je le sais, j'ai tendance à le
faire et c'est pas du tout une bonne idée
parce que lorsqu'on regarde un film le
soir et qu'on a envie de se détendre, on
éteint toutes les lumières comme ça on
est totalement immergé, pas de
distraction,
mais pour autant ce n'est pas bon pour
vos yeux.
Et le pire cas, le pire le pire le pire
c'est ce que je fais, poser la tablette
sur moi avec la luminosité au maximum et
dans le noir.
Ca c'est vraiment à proscrire.
Vous mettez de la distance, vous baissez
la luminosité et vous mettez une source
lumineuse à côté
Autre petite astuce, si vous commencez à
sentir qu'il y a une fatigue oculaire, que
les yeux picotent, que ce n'est pas
terrible, vous avez une technique qu'on
appelle le palming.
Vous posez vos mains devant vos yeux,
comme ça.
Alors bon, forcément comme ça, on ne voit
plus rien et on a l'air un peu bête.
Mais en fait, ça va venir reposer vos
yeux.
Vous pouvez également venir les fermer,
mais on va mettre une contrainte comme ça,
il n'y a plus aucune lumière qui passe.
Comme ça, vous vous reposez un petit peu,
vous prenez du temps pour vos yeux.
Alors bien évidemment, vous décrochez de
l'écran, mais vous les protégez, vous les
laissez un peu tranquilles.
Autre truc qui est super important, Vous
pouvez cligner des yeux régulièrement.
On ne s'en rend pas nécessairement
compte, c'est plutôt réflexe.
Mais on va venir cligner des yeux
énormément pour éviter un assèchement
oculaire.
Mais si vous sentez que ça pique,
n'hésitez pas à cligner.
Et puis surtout, pensez à bouger quand
vous faites des pauses.
Levez-vous, allez ailleurs, faites autre
chose, allez boire un verre.
Ne restez pas là avec votre ordinateur,
avec votre smartphone, avec votre tablette
à côté...
Pas tant pour vos yeux mais pour vos
muscles et votre corps vous dira merci.
Autre chose qui est importante lorsque
vous regardez un écran par exemple, un
smartphone.
Vous êtes beaucoup sur votre smartphone
comme ça.
Pensez de temps en temps à venir regarder
un peu loin.
Vos yeux vont s'accommoder, ça leur fera
du bien et ça va venir un peu les reposer,
ça les fera travailler différemment.
N'hésitez pas à venir cligner des yeux.
On a l'air un peu bête mais ça fait du
bien.
Et puis le dernier point qui est
extrêmement important en cas de troubles
visuels, de picotements excessifs, de
sensations d'assèchement et surtout de
taches sur l'écran, pensez réellement à
venir consulter un ophtalmologue.
Puisque je vous parle de sept erreurs, il
y a également 7 erreurs que l'on fait tous
et qui viennent détruire la batterie de
nos smartphones.
Pensez à aller voir cette vidéo, comme ça
vous allez l'emmener beaucoup plus loin et
ça c'est une très bonne chose.